whoa whoa i feel like i missed something
can i forget a whole part of the meal
tbd i guess hey it's kelly today i've
got 20 minutes to make a three-course
italian dinner i actually feel pretty
confident about this i know i can do it
and i'm excited so let's get started
okay first i'm gonna salt my water i'm
making some pasta
i'm gonna turn on this burner
to crisp up some prosciutto not
prosciutto pancetta
all right we'll let that get going
mean
meantime
so let's go and let's make some pesto
for the flatbread pizza we're having oh
sorry i should put the flatbread in the
oven first
that would be smart
okay 425 degree oven for like five
minutes now i'm gonna make some pesto
i have some pine nuts i'm gonna do one
big clove of
garlic
okay some basil
i like using these mini food processors
for pesto because you can make it in
smaller batches and then you don't have
a lot
left over
okay needs a little more
okay
coming together i'm gonna add some oil
some salt
and some parmesan
okay let's taste it
perfect
okay we'll let that set this pan is hot
i'm gonna add some pancetta
now i'm making the sauce for our
pasta i'm making a butternut squash
alfredo
so first i'm going to crisp up some
pancetta
and i'm doing this because it just cooks
like a little bit quicker and it's
already pre-chopped for me so one less
thing to do
so i'm going to let this crush up about
halfway and then i'll add some sage
leaves
to get those fried as well
so while that's going i'm going to start
on dessert which is a take on
cheesecake because that feels very
italian to me but i'm going to do a
cheesecake dip
bring all this over here
i have whipped cream cheese
i'm gonna add in about
half a can of sweetened condensed milk
and whip this until super light and
fluffy
[Music]
i'm just gonna scrape down the sides i
feel like it needs a little more of this
[Music]
okay
putting that on hold so i can get my
sage leaves in and i just want these to
get crispy and fried almost so they like
break
and they can act as a garnish
so i still have to make my pasta sauce i
have to cook the pasta i will add that
to the sauce right now
these take how long six minutes i'm
gonna set a timer because i always
forget
well we'll see how that turns out okay
15 minutes
flatbreads aren't done stir our noodles
i feel okay so far this is my tip of
cooking so
even though i'm irish i feel like i can
handle this i feel good the sage smells
so good
the pancetta smells porky bacony i don't
know it smells good okay
okay bring this down to low where's my
shallot where's the i'm gonna add some
shallot
i'm gonna thinly slice this so it cooks
faster and this will start to be the
base of our sauce our butternut squash
alfredo
i feel wonderful there's some peace and
quiet
kinda
so usually i have two screaming kids at
home
one to be picked up or
held or want something from me so this
is actually kind of
nice to cook in peace
and i'm just adding some smashed garlic
cloves don't worry about chopping them
because we're going to puree this whole
sauce
if i wasn't on
a 20 minute time limit i would say this
meal would take 30 to 35 minutes okay
let's check our flatbread perfect
flipping it over get a little more
crispy
i'm gonna add some more oil to this pan
some salt
so i'm just letting these shallots saute
in the renderings of the pancetta
it picks up all that flavor from the
bottom of the pan and adds a ton of
depth to your sauce okay so we'll do
that
moving back to our dessert
we whip this one more time
okay
now i'm just folding in some whipped
topping to give it that nice airy
texture of a traditional cream cheese i
mean cheesecake you just want to gently
fold it in so we don't lose all that air
but let me check this okay
this looks great now i'm going to
deglaze the pan with a little white wine
that will help
pick up any remaining last bits and then
also add flavor and acidity to our dish
because this is a pretty rich sauce
so now i'm going to add butternut squash
i like getting the frozen kind because
it cooks faster and makes my life easier
okay stir that together add some chicken
stock about a cup i'd say we just want
to get it super tender so we can blend
it up
cover it bring it back to a boil
hopefully that cooks soon let's check
our sauce whoa
and lastly
our
flatbread okay guys this feels messy i
gotta clean up hold on if my space isn't
clean i feel like my brain's foggy and
that's all i think about let's let these
cool a little bit and move back to our
dessert we're just gonna plate it up in
a bowl how much time do i have
well i think we're doing pretty good
actually then i'm going to dollop some
jam so this is where the strawberry
cheesecake part comes in we're just
going to add a little bit of jam on top
and then swirl it in in like a pretty
marble design
we have
cheesecaked it just gonna go back and
forth creating like a nice ribbon effect
and i might add a little bit more just
so it looks a little prettier
okay
that's it guys serve it with some graham
crackers
okay done done done let's check it
not cooked through so my timer never
worked on the pasta so we're just gonna
have to guess it's not done i just
touched it okay
so let's move on to
our appetizer so we got this beautiful
pesto we made
okay
okay so our appetizer is a flatbread
pizza with basil
pesto burrata and sun-dried tomatoes
so you can use store-bought pesto but i
really wanted to challenge myself plus i
just love the color of homemade pesto
it's like that nice beautiful green
color sometimes when you buy it from the
store it's like brown almost i think i'm
just going to do one this was back up so
enjoy tomatoes
eight minutes okay well i already have
dessert done appetizer is almost done
the pasta is cooking i have no idea how
much time's left because my timer didn't
work but i feel pretty good actually so
good i could probably like i kind of
poured myself a glass of wine okay
errata
so i'm just cutting some nice chunks of
burrata i'm just gonna place it
scatter it around
and kind of let the inside ooze out
okay gonna come back to that let me
check my noodles
okay they almost feel done let's check
this
okay so you can see when i break up i
can break it up easily with the spatula
so it is done i'm gonna transfer it to a
blender
[Music]
blend it up
please work
now i'm just going to add in some heavy
cream to give it that traditional
alfredo
vibes
oh gosh okay
okay pour it back into our pan whoa
look at that it's already bubbling up
that's beautiful
okay
let's taste it
it needs a lot of salt i'll tell you
that cheese cheese let's add some
parmesan cheese
i like to add the cheese in batches so
it melts evenly and doesn't clump up
on the bottom of your pan or in one part
of the sauce whoa
okay
so this is the perfect consistency
before i drain the pasta i'm gonna save
some water in case i need to thin it out
once i add the noodles whoa
okay
[Music]
okay these feel great
so instead of draining pasta you can
just add it right to your sauce one last
dish to clean up guys i've made a mess
look at my stove
okay good enough good enough
five minutes okay so i have to plate
this
finish plating that
and that's it
guys
i think i'm gonna get there i think i'm
gonna do it okay
turn this off i'm gonna let that sit for
a little bit and come back to this
beautiful masterpiece all right i'm just
going to cut it in like fun little
triangles so everybody can just grab a
piece
drizzle it with some more olive oil
every just always that olive oil it just
it makes it prettier and it tastes
better
3 minutes 30 seconds all right here we
go
you know what i forgot to add was a
strawberry to the top of my dip
i'm just gonna fan it out this feels
very old school
but i don't
okay so you can see my thoughts nice
so you can see my sauce has thickened up
like kind of past the point where i want
it so i'm just adding some pasta water
to thin it out and make it feel luscious
but still
i don't know i just don't want it to be
too thick and taste weird in your mouth
okay i'm gonna add back some of this
crisp pancetta and sage save the rest
for garnish we'll let that hang out and
just kind of clean up a little bit
because this is driving me i feel like i
missed something did i miss something
did i forget a whole part of the meal
tbd i guess
two minutes wow
the question is can i do it neatly
i don't have to like rush this is
pretty good i feel good let's just hope
it tastes good
oh see i told you i couldn't do it
neatly and i'm gonna have to go clean it
this looks amazing it smells even better
to be honest it's creamy it's luscious
kind of healthy because we added
vegetables but this is like to me the
ultimate comfort food like on a cold
winter night you want something quick
but tasty and feels like home
one minute okay the last thing i have to
do i have 48 seconds is just garnish up
my dishes with some of that leftover
pancetta and the sage leaves you can
like hear how crunchy they are and they
just look so pretty i think 30 seconds i
almost forgot to garnish with basil this
is my favorite part it brings out
same flavors as the pesto and it just
looks so pretty guys
that's it i did it
i did it
i'm done
i made a three-course italian meal in
under 20 minutes i feel really good
about this i feel like everything is
really pretty i know it's going to taste
good and it's a lot of food for 20
minutes i'd give myself a 10 out of 10
but let's see what it tastes like i'm
going to start with the appetizer
that is really awesome the creamy fresh
burrata pairs really well with the
crispiness of the bread and that fresh
pesto has a ton of garlic flavor now i'm
gonna try the main course i just love
the way these fried sage leaves look
just adds some dimension to the dish
this is amazing it tastes like an
alfredo with just like a little bit of
creaminess from that butternut squash it
is so good and last is dessert see if it
tastes like a cheesecake
that's actually really incredible
it seriously tastes like a cheesecake
and it was only three ingredients plus
some jam it is so good creamy and it
took what three minutes i'm so happy
with the way everything came out not
only does it look pretty but it tastes
amazing i gave myself a 10 out of 10
before this just based on looks and now
after i've tasted it i'm going to give
myself a 15 out of 10. you don't have to
time yourself on this but i promise you
you really can get this three-course
meal on your table in under 20 minutes
stay tuned for more of tc's 20-minute
meal challenges and until then i'll see
you next time
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you